Hi everyone, Sean Spitzer, Senior Instructor for Epic Games.
What we're going to go over now is we're going to take a look at OCIO color profiles
and some of the free tools that we have for you, and some of the concepts to be
able to get those OCIO profiles up and running to be able to be used for LED volumes.
We're also going to take a look at 3D LUTs and how we can grab an EXR HDR image
and convert it into a 3D LUT using a material.
So let's get started.
So the two things we're going to look at is the OCIO Open Color IO, the plug-in that
we've created that will be able to actually allow you to be able to use OCIO information
in a real-time environment.
And then we're also going to look at a material and how we can build the material
and get a 3D LUT to be able to conform to whatever color information that we want
to put into it.
So before we get deep into that, we need to actually first look at a checklist of some
of the things we need to consider when we're working with an LED volume in our production.
One, we need to expect to be able to send a 10-bit per channel signal from our GPU.
This is very important.
So consider what GPU you're using.
We expect LED panels on a stage to be capable of exposing their achievable gamuts to an
LED processor.
This is also very important.
So again, looking at your technology and what you have on your computers and what you're
taking to the LED volume is very important to consider.
Whether or not your processor is expecting your signal to be gamma-encoded or PQ-encoded,
things might look strange at first, but you're sending things to PQ-encoded output.
That's if you have that.
Now, I'm going to put a grain of salt with that because our system that we're working
with is not PQ-encoded.
We are gamma-encoded.
So we're using approximated light versus something that's a little more accurate,
more like actual light, and that would be more leaning towards PQ.
So again, this checklist, Unreal contains linear brightness values.
The goal is to have the linear virtual scene on the LED wall.
We are using approximated light here, so we're using gamma.
So gamma is a relative amount of light, not absolute.
So when you do use that, you have to make sure that your exposure is set to the
correct levels.
With PQ settings, the responsibility lies with the LED display, producing known light amounts.
Those are a bit more expensive, but that doesn't mean you can't seem to replicate
that on the same level when you're using gamma.
You just have to consider your exposure and exactly what your output goals are.
If using gamma output, use the end display actor exposure compensation to adjust any
incorrect values, also via the post-process color correction controls.
Now note, exposure for gamma will be different from what is used for PQ, so consider those things.
You can also, on the Brompton software, Tessera, choose from input if the PQ is not supported.
So I'm going to go to my screen here, and I'll show you exactly where that's at on the Brompton
and point out a few other things.
So let's go and switch over to the Unreal scene, and I'll pull over the Brompton display
so you can actually see what's going on.
So on my Brompton here, you'll notice I have selected the HDMI output here.
Over here, you will actually see you'll have an HD format choice here, and you can
choose PQ.
And again, ours is gamma, so we're using approximation here, so I have to adjust things
accordingly.
PQ, again, will give you a little bit more accuracy.
You also, in some cases, depending on the Brompton and the software you have installed,
will be able to actually load a 3D LUT within here.
Now we're not going to go that route, but that option is there.
What we're going to focus on is creating and using the 3D LUT information directly within
Unreal in real time.
So let me go and move the Brompton over here for a second, and let's go ahead and
go back to the slides.
We're going to turn up... one thing you have to make sure you consider when it comes
to Unreal is you turn off in your Windows display settings, you use HDR.
Note, you don't need to set your render nodes to use HDR mode in your operating system or
in your graphics driver control.
These are mainly used for game settings, so keep those things in mind.
You want to tell your graphics driver to signal and display 10 bits per component.
Make sure you are sending a full range signal, that's important, and your LED processing
software will let you know.
Now Brompton is really great for letting you know if your signal is not accurate.
We're not going to go over it in this particular class, but make sure you have someone in
your studio that actually can understand and read some of the settings for Brompton.
Here let's see exactly what our output is going to be and some of the things we're
going to be tackling here.
Now this is a little bit repetitive here, it's talking again about your PQ signal
versus gamma.
You want to make sure that once your scene is set up that you're considering the colors
that you need.
These color profiles will allow us to control color outside of the typical Unreal post-process
volume global settings, and having more precise control works well and it's going to allow
us to be able to do that within your end display.
Now one thing I do want to point out is 5.0 and 5.1 become more evolved, we're more
and more going to try to lean towards having your post-process volume like a normal and
natural workflow to be able to have that to control some of your colors.
But in 5.1, or 5.0 I should say, you're mainly going to be focusing on controlling that
within your end display.
You want to make sure your HDR settings in your Brompton software is set to PQ.
Now again this isn't for everybody's situation.
Your output may not allow you, your signal may not allow you to have that.
So keep in mind the gamma versus PQ.
And you'll see it happen as you saw the Brompton interface that I had.
If I had clicked on PQ, our whole wall would have gone black.
That tells me that the signal's not going to take that PQ output.
OCAO color management system, that's going to be used via plugin.
And I'll just point that out real quick here.
And that's how we're going to load our color profile information.
The 3D Lunt, we don't really need a plugin for it, but we're going to be building
a material to be able to digest that 3D Lunt information.
Now a little bit here as you see in the slides, there's some blue text here, which
is talking a bit about PQ and kind of breaking it down a little bit more so
you can understand how that works.
It is a transfer function developed for HDR that is able to represent
luminance levels up to 10,000 CDM squared.
It is the basis of HDR video format.
So that's why it's ideal.
You actually get better and more accurate display of light through your
LED volume.
And again, you still can use a gamma, you just have to make sure you
control your exposure and you know exactly what your final output is going
to be and get that to be a one-to-one, but it's going to be taking a bit
of tweaking, so make note of it.
So let's talk about setting up your post-process volume.
I have it here in my notes, but let's go ahead and go to Unreal.
I'm going to point out a few things that you have to consider when you're
working with your post-process volume.
So we have a post-process volume already in place within our environment.
And I have one here that's already generically set in place.
One thing you do want to make sure when you're working with your post-process
volume, that when you initially set it up, and let me go and cancel this
joining multi-user, I don't need to worry about that right now.
So I'm going to go and scroll down here, and what you want to consider is
exactly how big of a range you're having your post-process volume influence
your area.
In our particular case, we're using kind of a baked scenario.
Our stuff is baked within our environment.
It being baked within our environment, we want to make sure that we're
actually being able to influence the whole region.
Now, if I'm using Lumen, you do want to be careful when it comes
to infinite extend unbound.
You want to actually keep that within a particular region, and I just
wanted to make note of that.
Also, when you scale up your post-process volume to a particular
region, you're going to be able to just influence that region
if you need it.
So having an infinite extend unbound, just make sure you know exactly
what you're going for.
And if you're working with Lumen, just consider what your settings are and
what you have in the background versus your foreground.
And if you are getting a lag within your frames, you need to consider
exactly what's in place.
Just a note I wanted to put in there.
So some of the things we have to look out for, and let me go up to the top
here, is one of them is Bloom.
Now, in this case, I'm going to go ahead and turn standard and method on.
But in Bloom, typically, you want to have this at zero so that you can
actually control and see exactly what you're getting for your output,
for your brightness.
I'm going to keep this at zero, as I said, and we're going to keep
that set there.
So if we do need to increase it, we have the ability to do so.
So I have them active and ready to go.
Another one you want to be able to actually mess with is the
extend expander gamuts.
We're going to turn that expand gamuts on, and we're also going to
set that to zero.
Now, again, this is really important to consider these because some of these
might be on getting it from your outsourcing department, your virtual art
department, or even buying stuff from the marketplace.
You want to be able to look at these and make sure that these are corrected,
initially turned on to be set to zero.
And then if you need to turn them and adjust them later, you have that option.
One more we're going to mess with is a blue corrections.
We're going to turn that on, and we're also going to set that to zero.
All these things are, again, are very important.
So we're kind of getting a clean slate with our brightness within our scene,
and we're not getting any distortions or misgivings of exactly what we have
on a one-to-one.
So let's go ahead and go back to the slides, and we're going to take a look
here at the OCIO profiles that we have available to you to be able to actually
tweak and edit.
Now, I want to recommend something here.
We want to make sure when you're working with your OCIO that you have a
color scientist on hand, or someone is very familiar with coding with color
implementation working with OCIO.
It is preferred you work with a color scientist.
And we at Epic Games work with many because they actually help us to be able
to produce the results, and they know exactly what they're doing when it comes
to coding and getting our OCIO profiles up in the right direction.
So really do consider that when working with them.
Now, let's go ahead and take a look at things in the engine.
So we want to make sure, first up, that our plug-in for OCIO is active.
So we're going to type in OCIO, and you'll see that mine's already active.
So just make sure yours is turned on.
When you turn it on, you will get a restart prompt.
And we, of course, don't have to do that in our case.
And now we want to be able to actually see that information.
Now, we want to be able to actually view that engine folder,
because in there is our plugins folder.
So to be able to do that, you want to go to settings and turn on engine content
and plug-in content.
This is going to allow us to see the OCIO profiles that we've already
given to you.
So let's go and take a look at that sample content.
I'm going to show you how you can do some quick workarounds here.
So if I go into my engine and I open up my plugins,
I'm going to scroll all the way down to my OCIO.
And you'll notice there's a couple of different OCIO folders.
There's the regular open color content folder.
And there's also another one called open color OCIO C++ classes.
So you actually can program into this and edit things
according to what you will, what you need.
But what we're going to focus on is mainly this OCIO profile.
Now, I do want to mention when you're editing and working
with these OCIO profiles, make sure that you
do have a color scientist on hand.
And I know I mentioned it several times here.
But it's really important to consider
because they'll help you to be able to edit things
the way that you need instead of using or trying
to work your way in that landscape
and guess on what you need.
You want someone that actually knows how to code this
and to get the gammas, the colors, any resources
that you need in that particular profile
in the right direction.
So I'm going to go ahead and open up this folder.
I'm going to right click.
And I'm going to go to, in my content browser here,
I'm going to go ahead and go to Show in Explorer.
Now, you won't be able to see some of this data
because it's kind of treated in the content browser
like a Uasset.
So it is a bit invisible.
If I clicked on any of these folders here,
and I'm going to move this off to the side for a second,
you'll see that they appear to be blank.
But they're really not.
And that's why we actually opened up in the browser
itself.
So in my browser, go back to my folder, sorry about that.
In my browser here, you can see my OCIO
that I have these two folders.
And here we have icons to edit.
But we want to focus on this OCIO folder here.
And you'll see that we have LUTs and a simple config.
In the LUTs, there's ones that if you want to play with them,
and there's also the simple config, which
we're going to focus on.
But I'm going to, for the heck of it, grab both of these.
And I'm going to right click and say Copy.
Once I copy those, let's go ahead and close
this engine folder.
I'm going to go ahead and make, and you can see I already
have made it, a folder called Color Profiles.
And in there, I made a folder called OCIO.
So I can right click this OCIO folder now
and go to Show in Explorer.
And I can now paste that information.
And you can see it's replicated here.
That just makes it easy for me to get to them.
And I'm not trying to edit something
in the engine or plugins, which is really not
a good practice to do.
You want to be able to make copies when you can and put
them in a folder that's isolated so that you don't mess
with any defaults that you might want to reference later.
All right, with these copies in place,
we're now going to go ahead and make an OCIO profile here.
So I'm going to go to my Open Color OCIO configuration.
And that's found under Miscellaneous.
And you'll see Open Color IO Configuration.
So we want to make that configuration.
I'm going to click on this.
And then the icon's a bit different if you're used to 4.27.
No longer a color wheel.
I wish they'd put it back, but they haven't.
It's a raindrop on a pipe.
That's what it looks like.
I'm going to click on that.
And I'm going to call this one OCIO underscore in class.
And I'm going to double click on it.
So now this OCIO is ready to go
in which we can populate the information in the data
that we need.
First up, we need to look at that configuration file.
So this configuration that we've made,
we want to load the file that we're going to be editing.
So I'm going to go and click on that dot, dot, dot.
And we're going to go and grab the one
that we put in our color profile folder.
And we're going to grab this right here.
So we're going to grab that.
I'm going to say Open.
Now Unreal knows and has a reference folder
and knows what your output is going to be,
your subject of interest.
We want to go in here now and create color spaces.
This is going to be for where
we're going to send the signal
and receive that signal information.
So first up, I'm going to click on the Add element.
This element is going to be our utility.
This utility is going to be where we're working from.
So what I want to choose first is my linear sRGB.
That's coming straight from Unreal.
So we're going to click on that.
So that linear sRGB, we want to also,
you'll notice there is a delete and duplicate.
If you needed and you had several different volumes,
you have that option.
We're not going to mess with those here.
Just wanted to point those out.
We're going to click on the plus button again.
This plus button now will allow us
to be able to select our output.
So we have our utility,
where we're doing in all the heavy lifting.
And now we have our output
where we're going to send our final results.
You'll notice there's a PQ option.
And again, PQ is a bit more accurate than gamma,
but we're going to be working.
And like I said earlier, we have a gamma output here.
So that's what we're going to be focusing on.
So I'm going to click on that gamma there.
So we're now set with this particular profile
configuration, and I'm going to hit save.
Now let me go in and minimize this for a second.
So now what we want to do is go back to our end display
and in our end display, we want to load this information.
Eventually we're going to have it
so you can actually do this information
strictly through a post-process volume,
but we're working with 5.0
and that's not really an option right here.
So in that end display, with that selected,
I'm going to scroll down and we're going to go ahead
and find that color information that we need.
So let's go and scroll a bit here.
And you can type it in if you need to,
but it's pretty simple.
It's about halfway if you scroll
and you'll see the OCIO color profile information.
You want to make sure you enable viewport OCIO.
Natively, this typically is on.
You want to make sure that no one has turned that off,
but when you do have it off,
you will see a limitation of what you can do.
What we first want to do is do a configuration source.
So we want to grab that OCIO profile configuration.
Now you can have several at one time
that are loading color profile information
that your color scientist has already made.
So you can choose different ones.
If you need to switch between your gamma,
look and output and color, whatever it is,
you can load a bunch of these in here
and choose them according to what the needs are
for that particular shot
or if the director is wanting some changes.
I'm going to click on the OCIO in class.
And now you'll see your source color space
and your destination color space.
What is our source?
Well, it's the one we already designated, the linear sRGB.
What is our destination color space?
Aha, there we go.
Output, LED volumes, gamma 2.3.5.
Here we go.
And we're set in the right direction.
You'll notice this also in my slides,
but I'm going to stay in the engine right now,
but you'll notice that we have set up here.
You can also set your OCIO display here.
So you can actually get a one-to-one
and make sure everything's kind of going
in the right direction.
Do you always need this?
Well, it just depends on how your IT department
is set up, your monitors, are they calibrated correctly?
Is everything going in the right direction with your LED?
Are they talking to each other nicely
and is your color information correct?
That's pretty much what you have to focus on,
but you have that option here to be able to edit things
if you need to, to get a little more help
in the right direction.
Again, you'll have, you'll notice your profile
we can select, and then from there we can choose
what our utility is and what our output is.
It's pretty much similar to what we had here
underneath our all viewports color configuration.
So you can set it on a more of a micro scale
and this one is mainly going to be helping
with the pushing things to the LED volume.
All right, so let's go ahead back to the slides
for a moment and you'll see that I walk you
through this same system I showed you just a minute ago.
We see that we can actually create our configuration,
we load our configuration, we choose what our output
and utility is going to be, and we also take
in consideration exactly each one of our files
and you want to be able to enable, like I said before,
your OCIO viewport should already be active.
Select your source you just made
and choose the color spaces you also just made.
So that's pretty straightforward on that level.
And again, working with a color scientist,
you'll see my note here again, is very important.
They will be able to help you in the right direction
versus going in there and maybe hackily trying
to get it to be in the right look.
It's really important to get this look down
and you want to get people around you
that are able to do it cleanly and professionally.
So again, like I said before, in your viewport,
you can control some of this data
and that can be helpful to you
if you need a little push in the right direction.
Also notice, when you enable these settings,
the viewport disables,
and this is something very important,
I don't want to forget to mention,
this disables the tone curve
and inserts color conversion into the post-process stage
of the rendering.
So this is something that can be very helpful
in some cases.
Now, this really just depends how your initial setup is,
is your color information,
is your OCROs going in the right direction,
but when you put it in your display,
again, this viewport disables the tone curve
and inserts color conversion
into the post-process stage of rendering.
It does this right after Unreal Engine applies
the tone map, but before everything else.
So you may need it in some cases
where you see that you're not getting an equal
or correct color output.
So color management.
Now we talked about how the post-process volume,
let's go to Unreal just for a second here.
So in Unreal, you'll notice the regular workflow
that you'll have outside of an LED workflow.
You'll have your regular post-process volume.
I'll be able to scroll down
and I'll be able to actually mess with my color grading.
Now you really don't want to do that in 5.0.
Now in 5.1 and other ones that we're pushing further,
you still have to be careful.
It's better to work through the end display,
but our end result, we do want to have it eventually
where your post-process volume is being able
to influence everything like it normally would.
But in our case, since we're working with 5.0,
we want to be able to actually work off of our end display
for this color grading information.
So let's go ahead in that area.
So I'm going to click on my end display again
and I'm going to scroll down,
or actually in this case,
because we're already lower here.
We're going to scroll up to our color grading.
We can adjust our exposure compensation
and you can also say, hey, this is what I'm looking for.
Enable entire cluster color grading.
So you can turn that off and on.
This now activates it so you can actually go in here
and control it as a whole.
And if you turn that off,
if you click on them individually,
you'll notice when I turn this off,
I can still go in here and click on these
and that allows you to pick walk through it.
You want to be able to have everything.
You'll notice this is the fustrum.
Sorry, I'm clicking on the wrong one there.
You'll see it's flickering there.
You'll notice when you mess with the color grading,
it doesn't prevent you necessarily to go in here
and still clicking on these.
Just makes it so that everything's active at one time.
Sorry, I was clicking on the wrong thing there
for a second.
So we can go in here and now control this.
And this is ideally where you want to control
your post-process color information.
Note, your end display color correction
in your global settings is going to be different
than your post-process volume.
What you do in your end display
will not necessarily show up in your construction area.
So make note of it.
And you might want to make a post-process volume
to overall analyze things before committing.
We talked about how it's very important
to consider what you are doing in your scene.
Your iCFX camera in the scene in your NBC asset,
AKA inner frustum, can also have an OCIO profile.
So you can actually load it in there also.
So you do have to be careful when you're doing this
because if you're not managing and watching
where you are loading everything,
how you are messing and stacking your OCIO profiles,
say like I'm working with my OCIO profile,
I created a 3D lot, I went in my iCFX camera,
and let's go to Unreal for a second.
And I can now, you'll see there's an OCIO information
we can load here.
You'll be, if you're not careful,
you can stack things inappropriately
so that things are actually influencing each other.
And you'll be like, why is my color off?
So you've got to be careful with that.
I like personally to load it just within my NDC,
but you do have the option again
to load it within your camera here within the NDC.
We're not going to do that,
but I wanted to point that out
just in case you click accidentally on it
and you're like, oh, this is where it's supposed to be.
No, you can go there, but you have to keep track of it.
Otherwise I would recommend maybe doing it
only through the NDC.
Let's go back to the slides.
So you'll see color grading is applied
to the interface trim in this manner.
Post-process volume and display root actors
entire cluster color grading,
iCFX camera components, all nodes color grading,
and iCFX camera components per node color grading.
You have to be careful on which ones
that you're messing with.
So I just want to point that out.
And you make sure you don't stack them inappropriately.
We're going to go to the next slide here.
And in here, we're going to create the image
to embody a 3D LUT,
and we're going to talk about how LUTs work.